they came in the tens of thousands to
Bangladeshi Capital opposition leaders
activists and other groups all demanding
the resignation of the government they
said the last two elections were
fraudulent
from our Mass rally we have one demand
that is Sheikh hasina's government must
step down it's not just the party
members who are here Mass people have
also gathered
many have come from different parts of
the capital and the country to take part
in this rally that's despite a river
that cracked down by police hundreds of
opposition activists and leaders have
been detained since Tuesday
despite intimidation and harassment from
the police taking risks of Our Lives we
have been able to gather here to demand
our rights everyone is enraged as their
rights and freedom have been curtailed
under the government
the opposition here has held a number of
rallies and Road marches across the
country and in the capital since
beginning of the month many people are
also angry at the government for failing
to stop soaring energy and food prices
supporters of the governing Army League
party also held a large rally in Dhaka
on Friday just a few kilometers from the
opposition rally the political climate
here appears to be increasingly
confrontational ahead of general
elections later this year
Alliance for democracy have gathered
here in noapol in the capital city they
have only one demand the government must
step down and call for a caretaker
interim government internet service was
disrupted in the rally points
authorities deny shutting off the
services
knowledge mobile phone connections were
not shut off however the particular
mobile tower has a specific load
capacity it could become slow if it is
overloaded with tens of thousands of
simultaneous calls
the opposition Alliance say it will
continue to press home its 10 point
demand that includes the resignation of
the government and the transfer of power
to a non-partisan caretaker
Administration before the next general
election canvi chaudry Al Jazeera Dhaka